give five reasons why he won in 2016
okay
why he won so you could say a person you
could say uh whatever give five reasons
why you think Trump won in 2016. five
reasons all of us together
but why he won yeah humor okay humor is
one uh because the person was going
against Hillary did all that stupid [ __ ]
okay so so right there so let's just say
a terrible opponent that's terrible what
else give another one why he won uh the
Celebrity Status his uh okay coverage
yeah just news constant coverage by
everybody
okay and then what else
okay fine you put that one as well that
five was money I think there was a deep
year I think you guys were missing a
couple things or something yeah out of
the swamp
whether it was Bernie or whether it was
Trump yeah just not your typical
politician yeah I think they're Hillary
that robotic yeah I'm with her I'm just
there was a resentment
what are my handlers tell me to say yeah
where Trump is like handlers yeah check
out these hands I'm grabbing by the
[ __ ] right now I'm giving [ __ ] like
it's also a lot of people who like have
felt we were talking about this like
there's a lot of people who just felt
completely forgotten and
and when you give a nod to people who
feel forgotten
they can look past all the other dubious
[ __ ] that you say because finally
you're being spoken to okay yeah can I
give you a couple mine please check this
out okay so so here's here's the real if
we were if let's just say Trump right
now call this in the middle of the
podcast said guys I've made a decision I
want to hire you guys as our campaign
manager the four of you you guys are
helping us up yes
Malik for sure because he's got to do
Google he's got to search stuff yeah a
black guy so so so here's here's what
you got so you said comedy you said
Hillary bad opponent you said he's a
Celebrity Apprentice you said the
coverage by everybody and you got money
okay so what's the same he's still funny
but little bitter yes before he was
funny he's bitter now he wasn't bitter
back then right I agree he was an
underdog there's a different energy
between Underdog coming up versus a
bitter that Underdog energy is gone yeah
so there's no longer that Underdog
Spirit right that if you think about the
underdog correct because he's like oh
you're doubting me now it's like so does
he does he still have the money yes does
he still have a bad opponent he's going
to go up against yes there's still a bad
opponent so is he still a celebrity yes
is he still going to get coverage no no
he's not going to get covered there's no
way he's going to get the same CNN MSNBC
have them on their lesson so that's gone
right now here's a couple other things
kellyanne Conway was one of his best fly
carriers he lost her she's not doing it
this time she's gone she would go on
MSNBC CNN they would invite her and she
would defend him better than anybody
else that one is gone the next thing
that's gone he said he's not coming back
to Twitter because when he did the SPAC
deal I'm willing to bet if I gave Trump
a few hundred million dollars I'm only
paying your spack if I tell you one rule
will give you this uh 200 million
dollars whatever the amount was that
they gave him for this pack you will
never tweet as long even if they let you
back on you will not use Twitter so he
said I'm not going to be using Twitter
just come to truth so Twitter is gone
wow here's the other one that's gone you
ready uh is there a was there an
alternative to him at that time who uh
Huckabee a Rubio Jeb Bush Scott Walker
Ben Carson crew Ted Cruz
Ron Paul Kasich so but there is an
alternative today you're right so that
is the part and it's a real alternative
that's an option right that
you have to look at the drama does he
have Facebook today no does he have
YouTube today no does he have his
daughter today no right his daughter
said I'm not part of the campaign I'm
out so so the part that you have to kind
of think about and then Schwartzman I
don't know if you guys know powerful
Schwartzman yeah he said I'm not I'm not
supporting Schwartzman Schwartzman is a
in the financial space this guy's a uh
uh right there Schwartzman is the CEO
Blackstone Group Blackstone he said I'm
not supporting this guy's worth 30
billion 40 billion what's his number
right here zoom in a little bit [ __ ]
27.5 billion this is a guy that straight
up went against Rahm Emanuel and went
against you know Obama and wasn't afraid
so the the challenge with all of this
stuff yep he doesn't have the same team
as he did before and there is a real
alternative today so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valutaman it says future
looks bright here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red our black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks bad toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]